the Internet is a weird and wonderful
place and today we're going to explore
it legally blind
Spindler
good.com great one sa type or calm it's
finals week and have to finish my
American Civil War essay immediately so
now it's gonna write Civil War there was
a cat that pooped and I just need oh my
god
gotta work so fast this essays gotta be
done tomorrow
I finished they're so much work the
fluidly of PewDiePie Felix Arvid /
better known as beautiful eyes visually
what how these work how does he know the
quiet place project calm we forgot to
take a break from time to dam a real
break I walk in the park or a vacation
in the man's can be so sweet but if you
keep taking your phone with you how did
you really accomplished anything
burdening your mind with all those
meaningless building
meaning there's little things such as
this [ __ ] website about that meaning
this letter they shut the [ __ ] up you
pretentious piece of [ __ ] a friend made
a comment about your post a friend
shared a video with you a friend invited
you to a party a friend liked your link
a friend checked in a friend this a
friend that a friend a friend a friend
meaningless little [ __ ]
relax for 30 seconds don't do anything
else you can do it really you won't die
it's just 30 seconds
[ __ ] this [ __ ] zombozo calm
thank you as I'm become alright this is
okay I'm bored already do something will
you said that this is a [ __ ]
it's my new favorite website
I'm a [ __ ] guard dogs calm all right
seen this one I summed in not to da du
cambogia nanny gland surimi yeah gold
man calm slash texture what is this
okay that's pretty cool okay let's draw
me looks like a penis in my face good
job pitch uh-huh a squirrel shooting
lasers in space now any again okay nice
today
I would spend the rest of my days on
this website because really what else
should I be doing it kiddie weeks best
website on the Internet
okay that was a bunch of weird website
wasn't it good time stuff good times if
you enjoyed this one more leave a like
click here for similar videos rhosync is
so much watching that we'll see you in
the next video as always sales the
epicenter of the Internet